[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe what's up everybody
i'm christie stefano and i'm sal volcano
and this is
hey hey hey
babe um so yeah dude
i just feel like yeah yeah dude yeah you
can't you wanna
yeah do it over hey babe the thing is
yeah
i'm coming at you i'm coming at you
still buzzed from last night so you're
gonna get it all thrown at you
do you um do you do uh uh would you just
say yeah you have to do it
you yeah do it with anybody bobby kelly
maybe yeah well yeah you know what dude
i say yeah dude or you know what i've
been doing a lot lately
and i gotta shake it off i've been
calling a lot of people guy but like
but not like you know just like hey
what's up guy and it's just strange
yeah guy sounds um a little bit like um
passive aggressive right uh if you say
to the wrong person like i don't know a
guy
guy you know like a guy it's like you're
casting them off
i tell you what i always hear and i i
think i'm gonna set as a teenager i had
a
a little bit of a popularity run when i
was little but like i i wish i could
pull this off i wish i could
but it also can seem disrespectful too
sun what's up son yeah yeah yeah yeah
well not like that that sounds like
you're my friend
but like nah son i don't know i don't
know i don't know sun
sometimes sun people see that as like a
sign of like i'm your superior maybe or
something like that right
you know dude what up son the word dude
has been around since the 1880s
i would have never thought that the word
dude i thought
you dropped a dude when they were going
for well water it was a new word for
dandy
an extremely well-dressed male was a
dude wow
and dandy meant an extremely
well-dressed man
so a man who paid particular importance
to how he appeared
was known as a dude like a metrosexual
yeah that yeah the cafe society and
bright young things
of the late 1800s and early 1900s were
populated with dudes
wow extremely well-dressed man
yeah so you're a dude so right now we're
not dudes no i've been a dude in my
lifetime
maybe and of course i just want to give
a shout out real quick to tom brady and
the tampa buccaneers and i would be
remiss if i didn't mention the kansas
city chiefs hell of a game they played
shout out patrick holmes
great kid listen i got stand up dates
coming okay chrisdcomedy.com we just put
a big one on sale
today october 23rd the fox theater
foxwoods connecticut it's my first big
theater
thousand seater baby so go to
christycomedy.com
get those tickets for the october 23rd
foxwoods date
right now today to the end of today if
you used a pre-sale code fox5
pre-sale code fox5 you can get tickets
early they're selling very quickly
october 23rd and then we got providence
in july
eatontown new jersey in august nashville
in october we got
september dates november we're in boston
we're all over the place
chrisdcomedy.com thank you so much
well i feel like the new dude does wear
athleisure i feel like this is awesome
you texted me last night you sam you're
wearing your lemons
yeah i said i'm gonna wear my lemmies
because they're also what i like about
lululemon is they also double as fat
pants
lululemon yes lulu they're double as fat
pants they do
yeah anytime you get elastic in that
waist what are you going on right now
nikes i do have on nikes uh i had on a
i was going to put on my lemmy's shout
out nike i was going to put on my
put on my lemmies and i wore them um to
the drive-in movie theater last night
right and i got a little dirt on them
let me ask you something the drive-in
movie theater you went to it last night
you had a good time i
you know you said the movies weren't
great but what can you do you're okay
thank god
wait we got to cut that part out
probably because i'm not telling
that so what you just heard was
something that was
that could have indicted us both so
welcome back to the show
we edit that part out and you guys will
never know what we said but
keep the whole thing in just drop the
audio out and just come back with
zero detail and have us laughs all right
so do you think though
like i understand in you know in the
middle of the pandy we got to do what we
got to do
oh i love that i have never heard pins
pandy yeah they used to call a pandy now
they call it pood
poot so so so pandy
so in the middle of the paper in the
middle it actually takes the edge off
yeah
you know i was about to imagine the heat
of it in the thick of it like april 5th
yeah cuomo was like so info on today's
pandy
yeah everyone would have been like oh
maybe i'll go out you know
yeah cause if you say like the 1918
spanish flu the
horrible pandemic but if i said the
pandy of 2020 you'd be like that must
have been fun yeah panda
pandy yeah everyone had some down time
yeah pandy in 2020 what can you do
but do you think that because you've
experienced it now
you would continue to go to drive-in
movies even when the pandy is over and
moved there's a back open or
do you get now why drive and move
theaters eventually just close because
they're kind of it's nostalgic but it's
not that fun i will tell you yeah i've
only been to one drive in my life i was
young it was a double feature of indiana
jones and the temple doom and gremlins
wow it's nice back to back i remember it
vividly because it was like so unique to
me
never won again never thought of it
again i knew they still existed i didn't
know to how much right now i'm finding
out during the pandy
that they are scattered about right
because people do encounter i almost did
comedy there i am doing comedy there
yeah
um cape cod oh it happened already it
probably happened the shows went
the show went amazing yeah it is sold
out by the way
of course so um it did sell out um but
no what was i saying oh so uh
last night rejuvenated my faith in it
completely it's not a novelty thing
interesting it's like if if i was lived
near it it would be a regular thing i
did
okay so now how does it work you go do
you watch it from like your car
like you sit on the hood or everything's
through the radio you got to stay in
your car okay so
i don't know what non-pandy rules are
right pandy rules are social distance
cars so
they set up these stanchions and you
have to park your car in between them
and that's like the meter that you're
away from someone six feet
right you're allowed to get out and sit
in front of your or on the side of your
car
distance from someone else in chairs or
stay in your car uh if you
everywhere on the property is mask and
if you leave your
your box it's a mask but if you stay in
your little area
it's no mask no okay and you could you
could choose to
sit in your car and listen to it which
most people did
but i'd say 30 percent or 35
uh sat in lawn chairs which is what i
did and they rent you
they give you a little rental radio for
five dollars and you tune in like 89.9
on the fm
and you listen with headphones or you
listen for your group on like
on but like you hear it because
everybody's kind of like some people
have their windows down some people
don't
so you kind of hear it in the air but it
was a beautiful it was beautiful night
it was actually clear night so
just stars and everything and so the one
i went to
prior i remember when i was little had a
screen that way
and a screen the other way so a picture
a huge lot and half the car is facing
that way and have to cause facing the
other way got it so i would turn
now that i think of it i wonder if it
was a double feature or i just gremlins
was on the other one
right um but this one had three
different
movie theaters uh three different
screens all playing at the same time
and it you depending on what double
feature you went to you went to a
different lot
interesting yeah went to different yeah
the one i was in was the best lot of the
three
it had a full-on forest with like
50-foot trees behind it even bigger
actually and where was that one and that
screen was in front of that wall of
trees it was in warwick new jersey
shout out to the warwick movie theater
shadow warwick yeah also warwick rhode
island is a very uh interesting town
really yeah well it's just like colonial
town
this place was gorgeous like the last
half hour getting to it was
just huge lakes and foliage so this is
the one you went to yesterday in warwick
new jersey yeah yeah and this is the one
so you're saying the one that you went
to last night in front of the trees the
beautiful trees beautiful yeah i got to
go down out there it was nice we went i
was like they showed
some horror movies for me personally i
thought they were duds right but they
got really good high ranks on rotten
tomatoes
which is like a ridic like it's so what
about snacks and popcorn and stuff they
have a stand they have food they have
all that stuff you got to distance
online wear your mask
and that's it and that's it now so we
pulled up an article and again we're not
sure when this episode is going to come
out so who knows what the hell
uh the world uh is up to now but the uk
is doing their first socially distanced
concert
shows and we have a picture of it up
right here and it actually looks like
you can get some people in there if you
do it this way there's like these little
pods that you can have looks like three
to four three max i guess
seats in it and this field looks like
it's holding
a thousand people yeah that's gonna be
the way it's done i mean if it wasn't
distance you probably could put
probably 5 000 maybe 8 000 people in
that space but yeah but
yeah i mean if that's what it is it's
what it is i i mean i'd sooner have that
than not have any you guys can do you
you guys can you could get back on tour
like that yeah maybe we could i don't
know what that takes jeez
yeah it looks pretty cool it looks like
a hell of a production
yeah wow it's like they're standing on
their own little like
like risers yeah their own little like
uh
do you know what you you know how do you
rock out you know what's one of those
things
because sound you're like it's one of
those things where it's like because you
you know
have done so well and you know so many
people i i don't know that you know the
1975 the band
you only probably only know them through
me but if if i'm thir i'm going to be 36
by this
come 36 on my 40th birthday
i'd like if i'm not at if you know
hopefully we're all at you know we're
all just keep moving up but on my 40th
birthday if i can't do it myself
i'd like for you to somehow get in touch
with the 1975
and have them play me a song if it can
be in person great
if not some type just just telling you
now right on august 13th
all right that that for my 40th birthday
like something with the 1975 using
whatever you
the only favor i'll ever ask is pull
some strings with that god willing yeah
there's still a band uh you know yeah
because you have a few years to go there
yes but that's why i said four years i'm
not saying right to you
my point whatever you could do i've
heard of them i know them
i i don't know them as in depth as you i
anytime anyone speaks to them entirely
um i i imagine i from what i've heard i
really like them too i
should listen to him more if i had more
time but yeah we'll we'll figure
the 40th birthday gift just you know
yeah 40 that's what i'm going to do
because i've never i've never had sound
for anything but i'm just asking him for
that
maybe maybe the maybe they're on tour we
go to them
yes get the vip seats and maybe see we
can meet him
i mean who am i sure i don't know who i
am no but i'm just saying you know maybe
maybe if one of them in the band happens
to have
on the road on the road maybe they turn
on the the basic cable
listen do what you got if you got to
call your co-star paul abdul and she
does it then she doesn't just get it
done shut up paul abdullah great in the
movie
great at the after party paul abdul just
a great person isn't she great
great person yeah we're we're trying to
get her on dinner party oh oh so she she
would come
oh wow that's amazing she would no
because we do it all from home okay so
she's like
uh yeah we tried to she well she might
have been on already all right oh no
wait no this
no dinner party no yeah no it's all
confusing because that's
sometimes we do it in real time and
sometimes we're taping ahead so you
never know
but let me tell you paul abdul um i
had such a crush on her in like 1990 we
all did when i was when she when she
first hit really big with
because she was already a very
successful choreographer and dancer but
when she hit with her music
i was like i i was very smitten with
ball
i love paul abdul and uh how in the
world does
that i don't know how life works that
like x amount of years later i
she's in a movie that i i i you never
even can anticipate any of this stuff
but she was so cool yeah we had long
days you know you ended up sitting
sitting there waiting to go and waiting
for your takes and everything and in
between takes and
you just end up sitting there and you
you end up bullshitting with someone
that we end up you know hanging out for
days and days and days and hours and
hours now it's like a friend yeah it's
it's just wild and you just every you
realize everyone's just human you know
obviously but like
hey just sitting sitting there just
[ __ ] about whatever what uh what'd
you do this weekend
would you what'd you do me yeah what
what did i do i'm yeah
no because you talk i was like i was
like oh like we were talking
and you were telling me what you were
doing and i was like you got to just i
don't understand
oh you don't want to visit my mom yeah
oh
okay so it's just a fascinating thing
that i was like
you would never think that this is what
sounds like because i left you a message
and i and i left it as like i don't know
i just left it as a matter of factly
yeah but you call me back and you're
like that's the most insane thing
so my mom so i go visit my parents this
weekend
and um my mom you know my mom lives
alone and um
i shouldn't even say that maybe she's
gonna be like don't tell people i live
alone they'll attack me
sal's mom lives with actually four uh
four security guards
and six pit bulls yeah yeah like
seven-year-old maureen who killed the 20
year old hoodlum
yeah that's what it is she's actually
her tenant that's who sal's mom lives
with
yeah now my mom was my grandma but lives
with members of isis yeah so this
weekend
i visited my parents right my mom moved
recently okay
but during all the pandy right right so
we have to get our
furniture all that jazz and everything
yeah and i went this weekend and i told
her i would help her to get window
treatments because this woman
for the last april may for the last four
four plus to five months she
didn't buy like she didn't have blinds
or curtains
so what she did on every single room in
her house on every single visible window
pane
front door bathroom window everything
she taped wrapping
she taped she taped tissue paper
wrapping tissue paper
she taped it with scotch tape to cover
every single window in her entire
house okay so let me ask you a question
her shades her blinds are
in the entire home so if i'm not
with tissue paper for gifts so if i
knocked on the door
and she wanted to see who it was she
would have to remove the tissue paper
and then retake she's got to pull the
scotch tape down
remove the tissue paper look and then
re-adhesive
reapply the scotch tape was there any
was there another option that she didn't
think of or literally that's the only
option the lady had
okay so the first thing i thought was
what are you doing and then the second
thing i thought of was
this makes total sense believe it or not
it it
it lets light in yet it keeps privacy
the whole house you could do were
probably 89 cents
yeah easy and it's not a big deal it's
not cumbersome and she peels it away
when she needs to peek out
and she puts it back up when she doesn't
and it's it's already cut into sections
so i start at first i was like laughing
at her because it is ridiculous
right to live that way like go on
blinds2go.com shout out blindsico.com
yeah go up blog go on go on and what do
you take a measuring statement just say
give me a 36 inch vinyl set that's what
it is
10.99 throw it up but but it is pandemi
it's demi it's pandy it's pandy the
panda
it's pandemi it's pandemonium and uh but
sorry
but it's funny when you walk in the
house because it looks like a safe house
it looks like she might like she might
have to leave if she feels the heat
around the corner
in less than 30 seconds like she does
like she's like a wise man once told me
don't
don't ever be prepared to leave yourself
30 seconds flat if you feel the heat
around the corner
yeah you ripped that line from the movie
yeah well because what i did was i loved
the movie so much at me and my buddy
mike pacquiao
we were younger shout out my bachelor we
he
by the way wow interesting last episode
we talked about ghost stories
yes yes yes so oh then i also just doxed
him but anyway
uh what can you do but uh we love the
movie so much that we sat down
transcribed it which i used to do with
the jeffersons and then we took the
pacino into nero part where they were
sitting
at the table memorized it and when we
hung out we used to act it out together
wait a second
it was like in in fun we weren't like
being serious wait a second
so you used to okay when you say
transcribed it meaning you would sit
down and write the words watch the movie
write every single line for pacino
engineer when they sat at the table
together
and we and we memorized it and then when
we were together we would just bust it
out anytime we wanted
and you did that for the entire season
of the show the jeffersons
no i did that for jefferson episodes
with my family
i put on one man shows acting out all
the jefferson's characters
for my family when i live with my
grandparents up says nothing that
every night on wpix at 11 o'clock after
the yankee game
the jeffersons would come on and it was
my favorite thing in the world and so i
used to
write down the words and then i used to
re re-act it out for my family
[Laughter]
i'm not kidding do you have these
transcripts still somewhere i am a huge
jeffersons fan actually
i have um a lot of my fans know that and
so they've been so gracious as to send
me like i have like
the pilot episode autographed by them
and i watch all this it's my favorite
show of all time i've actually never
seen one episode of it my favorite show
of all time
so it's you so it's a must watch i mean
i love it it was a time when television
was different
and a lot of the sitcoms played like
plays actually right you really felt the
audience there
and it just like it was kind of like not
as polished as sitcoms today
it was more raw and it wasn't just about
there were hokey episodes but they
tackle especially all in the family and
jefferson's unknown
they tackled everything from race
relations and and
and and everything in between i mean
everything they so they they had
but it was like i don't know something
it resonated with me it was i was
watching i would watch it with my
grandparents too
and i think i just really love that time
i have a nostalgia for it yeah
but um but i saw i used to do that your
grandfather had a dent in his head
yeah right yeah yeah and uh my cubing
grandpa yeah
yeah yeah and uh and then uh so anyway
me and mike
we would transcribe we would transcribe
heat
and then we would drop it like in the
drop of that i think another thing i did
that with
yeah you can't handle the truth at one
point i could without even blinking an
eye
recite the whole courtroom scene you
think you get some right now
if you put it on you know when you put
it on and then you got me in a mode i
probably could
i could probably talk along with it i
mean it's been
but it's what you it's an interesting
thing to see okay let's see
okay let's see we're gonna put we're
gonna put on you can't handle the truth
to the two minute 39 second scene
we're gonna let sal watch it for a few
seconds and see if it kicks in
what is the movie you what is a few good
men about
i've never seen a few good men
yeah it's a must-watch there's there's a
lot of things men
a few good men is there was
like um
here we go and you curse the marines
you have that luxury the luxury of
not knowing what i know while tragic
saved probably save lives
comprehensible to you saves lives
either way i don't give a damn what you
think you are entitled to
you're goddamn right i did oh sick
i picked up on a little again dude even
just that scene i'm like i got to see
this movie
i mean that was the tour that was the
tour of the fourth scene though
yeah i was like you just kind of you
actually
you actually that that was kind of a
spoiler that's
because he is the code red and i the
whole movie was
uh just tell me what's the problem
what's the movie uh i guess
he plays a military superior who ordered
an assault on
a on a new office a younger officer
who he thought was a weak link and that
is like he's not allowed to do that he's
not allowed to order an attacker you
also get killed
uh no no but he was like it was
traumatizing and what have you i think
he was
just unceremoniously discharged or
whatever and then it went to court
and it was all and this guy is one of
the biggest most hard ass
egomaniac really respected generals
he was um in the army and it was all
about like
in the end tom cruise was like young
lawyer that took this case on i had to
get him
that was defending that was like
prosecuting i guess for him
and the whole thing was to he ended up
using
basically um uh
what the hell jack nicholson's ego
against him in the end there was right
it was a little like uh got it like a
little mental chest at the end
well it says tom cruise military lawyer
defending two u.s marines charged with
killing a fellow marine at guantanamo
bay
so they did die although oh oh sorry so
he died and tom cruise was defending
the two guys that were ordered to do it
from
god so they were on trial to go to be in
trouble and then he got
got it it was like it came it came from
an order but they didn't want a rat that
it came from an order
right something like that yeah no
there's so many movies that i just
haven't seen
that like because what i'll do is
instead of going home tonight and
watching a few good men
i'll just put on ace ventura when nature
calls for the
5 000th time no i get that which is
stupid because i'm
i could just watch so many new movies
but i'll watch the ace ventura movies of
the austin power movies
on repeat which tom yeah yeah i mean i
guess sometimes i'll just like throw on
something i know but i do like to like
take the boxes because we all have those
movies that we haven't seen
right you know what i'm not sure like
there's got to be some i haven't seen
what's some what do you think's the most
famous movie you've never seen
if you have to guess i don't even know
uh
hillary you got it top 10 movies of all
time
citizen kane never seen it never watched
it god's father never seen it godfather
i've seen it
dark night i've seen tonight is top 10
old time apocalypse now i've never seen
it never seen it pulp fiction seen it
seen it
goodfellas seen it psycho seen it some
like it hot
no never seen a shawshank redemption yes
2001 space odyssey yes
never i've never seen it early in 1979
yes
but it's been since then i've never seen
alien
chinatown yes but i don't remember it
that's like these are like
things i remember my parents doctor
strangelove lawrence of arabia raging
ball
all these are nose no strange love no
rabia yes raging bull
you could borrow my dvd raiders of the
lost ark of course of course
taxi driver yes vertigo i've never seen
yes casablanca
no no i've never seen one star wars
movie that's
not one you haven't seen so you haven't
seen the godfather
star wars what did you just tell me i've
never seen good men a few good men i've
never seen one of the star wars movies
do you go to the movies like when the
movies when it's not non-pandy i
yeah i yeah i go i'm a big big movie guy
but i'll go see movies that like you
can't believe
like i've seen the movie anne of green
gables 20 times
i don't even know what that is who of
what anne of green gables what is that
a pretty woman pretty woman of course
yeah
this is anne of green gables i've never
heard of it yeah of green gables
and there's another movie little women
um i've seen that
um now and then it's a great movie um
these are just the movies i used to
watch green gable it's just to scoop out
this girl anne
he's like little ass on the prairie yeah
it's just anna green gables just lives
on a farm a bunch of [ __ ] happens
hey babes man of greek gable yeah oh bob
they have a sequel i know what i'm doing
tonight
[Laughter]
dude yeah angry gables is sick
[Laughter]
you're gonna go to the theater you don't
go to the
theater and say one for anne of green
gables i would have
but i think i was a kid when it came out
yeah i remember this scene i um
i uh also you know little giants i
remember i've seen i saw that
i've seen yeah yeah intimidation yeah
yeah you use these for acid indigestion
what do you use them for
intimidation that's what i'm thinking of
right yeah the annexation of puerto rico
yeah um yeah dude i uh i uh
yeah i'm i like i just keep
i'm one of those guys where i i watch
the same thing over and over and over
again and it bothers me same thing with
books
i have i'm not i'm not lying cell about
60 books
that i've each book i've read about 10
pages in each of them
and as opposed to and i keep saying
telling myself
don't buy a new book until you finish a
book and i just have all these books
that i have
half read is that normal okay so i don't
know if that's a common thread with
everyone but i think it must be because
you just described
word for word every one of those books
you see
and i have another closet full of books
i might have read cover to cover
maybe five percent of them and
i haven't cracked the page
on more than half of them and then the
other 45 percent
i probably read between you know 10 and
60 pages that same thing for you mike
homeless pimp homeless pimp doesn't even
buy the books he said
wow yeah no i always tell i always say
the same thing don't get another book
yeah get another book and then i'll just
be on amazon and i get a book somebody's
like you gotta read the book
airport tactile i want to feel it like
yeah yeah
stupid you know and i just i just i
don't know what it is
never am i like let me just open this
book
and say you know it's terrible it's just
the way we're programmed nowadays well
it's called the mere exposure effect is
what we've pulled up there's evidence
not only that we replay songs that we
like but also that up to a certain point
we like songs
the more often that we play them so it's
the same thing with movies i think that
says we like something more merely
because we've been previously exposed to
it that's such a
that's i mean i can get behind that
theory that sounds like yeah
the mirror mere exposure to it i like
that they put mirror in there
i think even when it's like that's the
title of it like the mirror exposure i
think even when the panty
ends you got to keep this hair and beard
look i think this is your look
you have and this is no disrespect at
all but an
1800s type of look and an 1800s type of
face
and i've just realized that now i've
just realized that now that you got a
face that's that's for the 1800s
the way you look right now is if i saw
you
in some black and white photograph like
the union army
uh you know i would say this guy was a
handsome guy for his time
and i'm not saying you're not a handsome
guy now you're a very handsome guy now
you know that cell yeah but
with the look that you've got going on
right now a very civil war sailor you
look like you're
in the you look like you're in the union
navy in the 1800s
and it looks fantastic on you really
fantastic on it you know i've been doing
it straight back
a lot it's been it's been feeling again
it's been feeling cigarish
so i did the part today it looks great
but then i got then i got the flip in
the back which doesn't go
this is like neat and then this is not
to me it's the look i feel like i look
ridiculous i actually thought about it
after like the let like the parting look
in my bathroom
mirror before i left it yeah today yeah
i looked at it i was like
no but what can you do you have to you
have to you have to go forth you have to
go
get the forge full of it but the hail
like this with the flip like this it
looks like i'm very confused
yeah and i went to get my first haircut
right four and a half months
right and he cut off a bunch here and a
bunch here
and it feels it feels better feels
better what did marianna rivera say
about your hair
you got to meet marion rivera mariano i
got who's a friend of yours now which is
wild mariano i mean look this is the guy
that was like him and jeter the core
four right
absolutely new york baseball five six
rings each
i mean a lifetime yankee p this guy we
paid
we paid good money to see this guy play
we we were sitting at the edge of our
seats
most of the time when he was pitching
closing in big games
and he has a foundation um
uh charity foundation for children and i
and i got invited to go
to help with it and i went and i said am
i gonna meet him and become best friends
with him and it happened
and it happened and that yeah and now
rivera is just you know it's interesting
i think we're best friends
because rivera i i i hosted the show in
2014 called off the bat it was on mtv2 i
know this is an mlb
and i got to take batting practice
wasn't your co-host um
sway and fat joe yes yeah yeah
yes you took batting practice off
mariana rivera i got to actually step in
your mouth yeah i have it on my
instagram i got this that's another
thing yeah
i golfed with them yeah i very by the
way i don't know if you got to
bs with him no i mean what a just a very
sweet kind laid-back happy-go-lucky guy
yeah like whatever whatever you know
like kind of yeah
put it off the bat chris to stefano
marion rivera holy
cow i got practice with him when he was
sick
was he just was just lobbing him in just
like no he was throwing he was
he was throwing the ball were you were
you connecting well here's what happened
is i was in the batter's box with them
yeah that yeah i saw like the that's the
video of it oh my god dude
yeah this is it yeah
i think so big fan man from brooklyn
that's from the bronx
dude what were you thinking this day it
was crystal when you found out you were
gonna do this
could you pause that one second yeah
take me through this you you whose idea
was it
mm-hmm major league baseball pitched it
to
us as the show they i played in the
major league baseball celebrity all-star
game
and i got to do batting practice off
mariana rivera you're kidding i swear to
god and then the celebrity
were you nervous oh my i went oh for
three in a softball game in front of my
whole family
and popped out to the catcher
yeah who was pitching um um
was it lob blah blah blah yeah it was um
the guy from the minnesota twins i'm
i'm blanking on his name jack something
no but he was he lobbing or was he doing
like
another professional college like how
they do that thing where they wind their
own but no
it wasn't it wasn't uh yeah no it wasn't
like lesbian softball
it was yeah how fast can that can can
the lesbian softball girls uh
though really some might be like some
might not let's be
shout out shout out lesbians shout out
lesbians shout out softball i think they
go to the 70s or the 80s
on to hand underhand that's i think is
it that harder
90 miles an hour yeah the fastest pitch
on record was thrown by
oh eddie finger
underhand underhand what what
unnatural body position do you have to
do
to throw underhand that's got to be
harder than throwing 100 i mean it's
unquestionably harder to throw faster
underhand do you think
could a major league baseball pitcher
come in and throw i mean a woman could
then technically be a pitcher and just
come in underhand and rock you
yeah that's possible i i couldn't hit
that what she's throwing no
chance and then they throw off speed
curveballs too
um i wonder if that had that messes with
your body it has to
all that stuff all that stuff messes
with your body i i
i mean i can't even wrap my head around
where the control is coming from if i
got hit by a
softball pitch i'd hit the dead i cry
somebody'd have to walk me to first base
could you
honestly they should like like these
pitchers could be
like law enforcement if they just get
a sack of balls to walk around the
street like we're talking about like you
know do you want to take away bullets
yeah you want to start the riots again
bang i mean just those softballs are
going at them like
the i mean you almost don't see the the
winding of the
tendonitis may happen and the rotator
cuff there's a disease there's a not a
disease
a injury called little leaguers elbow
that's the knit it's called little
league elbow
really i've had to tell grown women that
you have little league elbow
when i was a physical therapist wow yeah
it's medial epicondylitis
you remember yeah and then tennis elbows
lateral epicondylitis wow that's fun to
say
yeah lateral epicondyles hola
mi nombre es cristobal nistefano
guess why i learned that babble that's
right i've been learning a second
language
and it's espanol la penguina babel's got
15 minute lessons that make it the
perfect way to learn a little
new language on the go here's the thing
okay
because you know you heard about all the
other ones and i've tried them i've
tried all the other ones too but
babel comes along and what they're they
have a teaching method that's
scientifically proven to work
with babel you choose from 14 different
languages spanish french italian german
and they have this speech recognition
technology that helps you to improve
your pronunciation and accent because
that's really what
learning a language is about is about
your accent and how you're pronunciating
it
okay so if i came in here and said hello
my name you know my name is
christopher hola my nombre is
christopher the stephanie said this guy
he doesn't know spanish but then if i
said hola mi amigo mi nombre es christa
you would say this kid uses babel and
you can use babel too and we got a
discount for you guess what
all you got to do get a three-month
babble subscription you know we're gonna
get you
additional three months for free so
that's six months total you pay for
three months you get three months free
all you got to do
go to babel.com and use the promo code
hey babe
that's babble b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
promo code hey babe extra three months
babble's the language for life
listen if you're a biological man like
me we're all looking for essential
brands that
have smart designs and we just want to
feel comfy want to be in our clothes
got the place for you mac welding okay
first of all their products are about
versatility you're not just going to
look great in mac welding their
underwear socks and shirts
perform well too from working out going
out going to work on or
on a date mac walden's for everyday life
and i got to be honest with you i have
some products from mac walden
and they're amazing if you know me i
blow holes through almost all my boxer
shorts because of my farts
not a whole insight in these underwear
okay i also listen you know i've been
talking about at leisure left and right
mack weldon
has great athleisure they offer a wide
range of customized fabrics that can
keep that can keep up with you no matter
what your day looks like
18 hours silver air knit drying it
warmness all these freaking knits okay
it's a knit nut shaft in here
i just made that up i don't know what a
nit neck shack is but it's that's what
it is
okay and here we got a deal for you all
you have to do
is go to macweldon.com
hey babe and enter the promo code hey
babe you're going to get 20
of your first order okay so that's mack
weldon m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n
dot com slash hey babe and enter the
promo code hey babe
20 off 20 off your first order okay
20 off your first order macweldon.com
hey babe enter promo code hey babe i'm
telling you
the fabrics are going to change your
life if you're like me and you're comfy
lumpy but you also want to hide your
puffy nipples mac walden is the place
for you
or like or like it was funny like being
in pt school and like physical
therapists going like learning about
like all the organs and like yeah things
like deep within the body like there's a
part of your
organs that comes right i think it's i
forgot it's like what organs on but
it's it's called the islets of
langerhans and that's the thing and it
would be funny because like you would
just people like joke around like how
you doing to that back i ate
something bad and i'm feeling feeling
the eyelid of lagrange
things like that i would drop that stuff
in casual conversation all the time like
yeah
oh you know you might have something
more when yeah the upper yeah lateral
epicondylitis metal epicondylitis
um uh sometimes i'll say nucleus
pulposus or your annulus fibrosis which
is just your spine
wow yeah i'll do [ __ ] like that so
you're going in
and you're thinking i'm nervous or this
is going to be
i were you in the moment like was like
this is a dream or were you
yeah i remember i thought that they were
lying to me until we actually got to
yankee stadium
and they i was supposed to get dressed
and young you look
yeah oh my god you actually look
different i know right
dude i look better there right you just
look different i look younger
you look younger you look more like
german there yeah
like yeah see this is me with a gopro on
my head
getting pictures to mariano rivera and i
just am whiffing
and i suck was there a comedy take
behind us are you trying to hit the ball
so what what i said i said i didn't want
to make any contact because i said you
know i'm such a big fan that god forbid
i hit the ball back at you
right you know and and then when i was
in there with him and they cut this out
i asked him i said can you just throw
the cutter can you throw the cutter his
famous pitch at me
and he was laughing he goes i i you know
i don't know and then he's about 60 feet
from you
no and there was a woman there was a
woman uh like a yankee
the woman running this thing like for
the yankees press or whatever
who said to me who was like standing off
to the side
and he was like um he was like oh can i
throw the cutter
and she was like i don't know she was
like you know it's a liability you know
like if you hit him or whatever
and then i was like you know you could
just throw it and she was like you
really shouldn't throw it
because she's a lady i know she goes you
really shouldn't throw it like
you don't know where it could end up and
then he sat there he said
to god that's him sway he goes he goes
uh sway was right there he goes uh
marion versus the woman he goes i'm
marion rivera i can place it wherever
you want me to
and then he threw it 95 miles an hour at
my chin
and i took a swing and missed and they
cut it because she felt
like it was oh my god it could be taken
as dangerous even though the whole
everybody was crowning around like this
guy's going to throw the cutter oh my
god
so i got to see as a you know guy
idiot kid who played barely high school
baseball they threw he threw a
marine of air through his famous picture
that's like it's like it's like like
like
make like the dream camp i felt like a
make-a-wish kid yeah yeah
i wonder if i do have a disease and this
is how they're gonna let me know
yeah i had the gopro on my head and uh i
remember
i remember being like extremely nervous
but i don't remember
a lot of parts about this day as a
matter of fact i didn't remember any of
it
until i found the video like deep in the
archives or somebody sent it to me
and i pushed it on instagram and i worry
about that with me i've had
big things happen like meeting marianna
rivera and getting batting practice off
him and i don't have a memory of it
and i don't know why and it bothers me
if you had that like
because i know you've had so many big
things happen in your career now but
have there been things where you're like
i can't believe i don't remember a
second of that
yeah it happens it's just weird it's
just i don't think we have enough a room
up there like do you remember
every moment of madison square garden or
there moments you're like oh i just
forgot because it was such an iconic
moment
yeah i don't remember every moment it's
crazy i i remember feelings
the feeling right i remember specific
specific moments
but overall i don't remember every
moment that happened to me a lot it
happens to me a lot
yeah when i sometimes i remember that
something really really really really
cool happened to me i'm like
oh why is it in that in my normal mental
rolodex
right like why aren't i calling that up
at will like i had to be like i would
have never remembered if i didn't get
jogged
by like something yeah like i saw a
video i saw a note or i started thinking
oh my god oh my god remember that like
it just escapes you
yeah that's like i went to i literally
uh
three years ago go to wrigley field
chicago this is 2017 go see chicago cubs
i chose chicago
go see the chicago cubs wrigley field
and i this is my first time ever at
wrigley field i'm at like wrigley
freaking
yeah and it's unbelievable whatever
talking
we're at wrigley field in chicago a
member of the chicago cubs
uh of of that works there like you know
walk around goes oh chris
welcome back and i was like
[Laughter]
and i was like what are you talking
about i had sal
done an entire off the bat episode on
the field
at wrigley field with their best player
anthony rizzo
i didn't remember a second of it i
thought it was the first time for the
first time i
was going there for the first time in
2017 i forgot
not only no hey babe not only not only
was i at ricket field i was on the field
with their best player who won the nl
mvp that's insane and i didn't remember
how do you not remember that and then
until they shout out wrigley field shout
out really feel it because it was one of
those days where we had filmed
it was like a thursday friday saturday
we filmed uh
you know in st louis then pittsburgh
then chicago and it was just one of
those i didn't remember at the most
iconic baseball field in the league
until they
yeah it happens to me with touring
because a lot of times what we do is
we'll go
uh like on a tour for three weeks
straight right every night is a new city
and a lot of times if we're on the bus
or what have you the bus pulls up like
behind the venue or whatever it is
we go in in an alley or in like a
service entrance yeah
and then we go into the green room and
then when we're ready to go on stage or
wherever it is like this way to the
stage
and you don't see the theater you only
see the stage when you go out there in
front of a packed house
usually yeah and so you don't see the
empty room i try to catch the empty room
on the way out if i'm for some reason
i'm still there after everyone's cleared
out
but like i don't get to see the front of
the theater or the awning
and so i don't have mental snapshots
associated to the locations and so and
then when i'm doing sometimes
you know 20 20 nights in a row right and
that's the same pattern
and then like sometimes we'll do three
of those tours a year
right you know i mean so it's like so
then like people be like oh we're going
to houston i'm like i know i've been in
houston
that know what venue you're playing i'll
have to like look and say oh this is the
venue have you ever been there and i'm
like
i'll maybe maybe remember when i get
there right i don't necessarily remember
right because i'm not i'm not
experiencing it in a way
right that is is you know so that
happens to me all
the time yeah it's it's bizarre because
i'm like am i not appreciative i know
i'm appreciative and i'm
so grateful but i'm like do i have
freaking alzheimer's at
35 no you know but i mean i remember the
big big big moments but yeah
what um wait so you so so mo so anyway i
ended up golfing with them for the day
and then eating dinner with them
and we i just had tons and tons of
laughs right and
he just he's already just like he's like
come back to the house i will barbecue
and hang out
yeah i was like the event i was it was a
very small
like charity like a pandy charity right
event so we had we were massive
we were masked up and so it wasn't a
pandy charity but it was the charity
during vandy
joshua messed up yeah um and but then it
was like we hit it off we were like just
just really nice his whole family was
there it was at his home right now it's
one of his home so
and then um and then so he's like you
know let's let's let's hang again
and like just come back and i'm like
let's yeah now like with the texas you
have an amazing home like like what you
what's up
like wow beautiful home i mean he's got
a few of them i think so i'm not going
to talk out of turn but yeah yeah god
bless the man yeah but
so one thing we're on the golf course
hello
fresh what's up yes love some hellofresh
we've talked about it before on the show
i've been cooking with it i've been
using this product they're great meals
they're calorie uh low meals you just
you learn how to cook i've been learning
how to i can now comfortably say i can
cook because of hellofresh okay
25 plus recipes to choose from each week
vegetarian meals to craft burgers extra
special gourmet options
there's something for everyone to enjoy
and that's the truth there really is
because i mean
you know jasmine's a vegan my dad you
know
eats animals live and my daughter you
know eats macaroni and cheese with ice
cream
so i can literally please everybody with
hello fresh
it has a wide variety of easy delicious
options for all for all three meals a
day
plus every snack and special treat in
between so they got snacks too because
you know me and chrissy snacks so i like
a little snacks i like
in between meals because the blood sugar
drops a little bit and hello fresh
is the place for me and i want to be the
place for you and we got a great
discount here
all you have to do is go to
hellofresh.com
hey babe12 and use the code hey babe 12
you're gonna get 12 free meals including
free shipping okay so they're not trying
to get you with the shipping they're
saying including free shipping all you
got to do
hey bae go to hellofresh.com
hey babe 12 and use the promo code hey
babe 12
for 12 free meals that's insane they're
going to give you a free meal for every
disciple i love hello fresh hallelujah
i have a rock hard [ __ ] and do you want
to know why i have an rhc
bluechew.com thank you very much rock
hard all the time so many
i'm so hard all the time that it's
actually embarrassing i'm like look at
look at i have a stiffy
and it's been great it's been great
especially with coven and keep
six feet away well people are keeping
three inches away from me
because of bluetooth.com and listen
here's the thing a lot of people
you know guys listen we go through we go
through male enhancement stuff you know
maybe you're a little older or maybe a
little younger and you're on steroids
whatever it is sometimes it's hard to
get your pishka deal
up in the air blue uh blue chew it uses
the same active ingredients as via
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and
listen i'm scared to swallow pills i'm
scared to swallow anything you know me
i'm a spitter i don't swallow
blue chew makes it chewable and it's an
online prescription service so you don't
have to visit a doctor's office because
that's embarrassing to have to stay with
someone face to face that you you know
you can't get your woodrow wilson
standing up this is online
and it's clinical you know real
clinicians licensed medical providers
and once you're
proved you receive your prescription in
days and the best part
it's all done online so uh um and
it's discreet dude nobody know it's not
like oh boner pills they don't do that
it's all discreet packaging
which i love i take it i take it okay
and
stiffy what you need to do we got a deal
for you you got to go to bluechew.com
you got to go to bluetooth.com and you
got to put in the promo code
hey babe sorry okay go to bluetooth.com
use the promo code hey babe at checkout
all you do is pay the five dollar
shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code hey babe
and you get your first
month free so we literally all you have
to do is go to bluetooth.com
promo code hey babe put in the five
dollar shipping and we're going to give
you a free rock hard [ __ ] for a month
that's on us that's hey babe's promise
we want to make you hard for 30 days
bluetooth.com promo code hey babe pay
the five dollar shipping get the first
month free
on us and then the rest of the months
that you want to stay hard you're gonna
have to pay for it but you use the promo
code hey babe but at least you get a
month free it's great i'm hard
and he i found out that he bought a
toyota dealership
right and i said public info the rivera
toyota
and i was like no way and i go let me
ask you a question do you have to do
those like local commercials
yeah like those corny local commercials
he's like yes i do i do them
and i haven't seen one but i was like i
said if you want i would i was with q
like we would love to do a local toyota
rivera toyota commercial for you yeah
and he's like
let's do it yeah so we're now working on
we're thinking of ideas to do
for a little followed up on this yes a
local
toyota of america but if you want to
pull up because then i went home
and i looked up a couple of commercials
and god bless
like some are so funny because he
doesn't either he doesn't speak or he
speaks but this is one dude
it's the cursor one duty i guess he has
a head salesman there or maybe it's a
partner i don't know who the guy is to
him
that works at rivera toyota and he
thought he goes in hard with a rap song
okay okay it's a local commercial he
goes in super hard with a rhapsody like
you could tell
he's a kid that listens to hip-hop that
wishes he could have
been a hip-hop artist right but he's not
that he's like you know he's in the
suburbs he sells cars and stuff
but he has a passion for hip-hop and i
think this is the kid this is the guy
yeah he's got his suit is too big you
could tell that he listens to hip-hop
because
he has like the hip-hop
flair in there and he's committing in a
way that's not like an awkward like
hippity-dippity like how when your
parents tried to yeah
but it's like he goes in hard but like
the lyrics are really about like
zero percent financing and then he and
you're watching it you're like wow this
guy is
really it's almost like it's like and i
might mean if he still works here i
might i might meet him and if he sees
this god bless the man shout out
shout out rivera toyota shout out this
hip hop guy but um
but you could tell it's almost like two
is like this is my chance to shine in
front of mo like mom spaghetti
and like and then and then you think
marion's gonna say anything and then
mariano never says a single word
here we go let's let's let's crank this
up
[Music]
if you're looking for a smaller car with
a low price got the yaris that could
roll the boat cars really nice want a
nice midsize
you talking about it carry number one
selling car great car
for the family next up you get an
accident right yeah
can beat the gas mileage on these cars
come and see if one of luxurious food
just look at it it's unbeatable by far
if snow when your budget is a prop get
it right for
the most affordable overdrive you could
ask for not
many been ready but need a third row we
got the highlander all-wheel drive let's
go
with time for the swagger wagon come get
a sienna
only
luxury and a whole lot of truck the
sequoia
the land cruiser worth the big bucks at
rivera
i mean he went in he was even like doing
the like you know like the oh
like you want like you know he was like
really like feeling himself and rivera
just said
by the way billion dollar smile mariana
you know did that did the off-the-bat uh
show and then i did
the uh mlb um the celebrity
uh all-star game in minnesota and
my dad came with me was a huge baseball
fan rivera was on the team he wasn't on
my team's on the other team but on my
team
was ricky henderson and ricky henderson
yeah so and so i was in the batting
cages and ricky henderson
talks in the third person so i was in
the batting cages
uh you know warming up for the game and
my dad's there and the cameras are there
and then ricky henderson starts saying
ricky henderson would put his weight on
the back leg a little more no
yeah sweet he starts saying no in front
of my father no he goes but he's telling
you
he's telling him what he would do but as
he in his third person
voice and he's going after their person
he's going ricky anderson will put a
little bit more weight on that back leg
there's that so my dad's like crying
that right this is giving his son
batting tips
and then he's like ricky henderson would
keep his chin tucked but that's what
ricky henderson would do
he was saying things like that laughing
swinging and missing
then we're on the team my team is me
andre dawson mike piazza ricky henderson
nelly um january jones
oh oh okay yeah fat joke wait nelly yeah
because it was
because it was a mix it was a mix
january january jones
uh uh nelly fat joe yeah go to get go to
go to christie
chris yeah 2014 celebrity yeah
i mean andre dawson andre hawk yeah
for i mean raleigh fingers are you
kidding are you
kidding me yeah i mean just hall of
famers oh uh oh absolute hall of fame
yeah maybe put mlb
or or like go to all too because you get
the article
um and so uh yeah there we go complete
roster
here we go let's see i forgot we go down
did nelly have the band-aid
yeah and do that mean by the way the
band-aid i don't know what it means
oh i think i read somewhere it was like
a tribute to somebody
yeah so my team was shout out band-aids
so it was andy cohen andre dawson
james denton who was from that show who
was from the housewives show real
housewives
on abc uh or desperate housewives then
we got me
jenny finch raleigh fingers dwight good
and ricky henderson melanie iglesias
that joe kevin love fred lynn charles
mcdermott maya moore jack morris that's
the pitcher who i struck out against
i popped up to nelly dylan o'brien zach
parisi
from the minnesota wild adrian peterson
for the vikings wow
mike piazza rob riggle ozzy smith john
small sway
jim tome and andrew zimmerman zimmer and
myth
jim tommy but but um the wizard
the wizard so i go oh for three and on
the bus ride coming home we took a bus
from the stadium back to
how how fast are the softballs coming in
they're throwing you were you in your
head or was it difficult to hit
it was i mean did january jones get a
hit not to say i'm just saying
january you played baseball she probably
didn't play college baseball i don't
remember if january jones got it just
jenny finch who was in olympic team usa
olympic
uh pitcher she was great jenny finch is
great she plays in every all-star game
um she it was embarrassing because i
mean i didn't even like
i went over three ellie's got is that
nelly up there
no who's that where oh that's my glasses
yeah that's that's well that's me in
january jones
go up go up one more mikey there you go
i had my pants too high
but that's me and january jones um and i
look like a loser a little bit but what
can you do
you look a young kid a cute kid with it
with confidence with his hat backwards
yeah yeah
yeah i i look i i have a little it looks
like i have a little penis in that
picture and i'm not saying i don't
um the bottom left with the picture of
you and finch yeah you got the thing
where you did the hat to the side and
back
yeah which is a little corny now looking
back but what can you do
but um but yeah melanie iglesias uh did
get a hit and i didn't
but going back on the bus ride on the
bus ride going back to the hotel
um i was sitting with my father and
ricky henderson and ozzy smith were
incessantly making fun of me for popping
out to the catcher so much that my dad
got involved
no by the end of it my dad ricky
henderson was saying
you should be embarrassed that you got
you guys got the same last name and i
took my jersey off and my dad took the
jersey off
and didn't allow me to wear the jersey
because he was embarrassed by the last
time on the jersey
because i went over three fast forward
the next morning i called my i wake up
and my dad were in the
same hotel i wake up my dad's not there
give him a call i said what's going on
he goes oh just out
just out to coffee with ozzy i said what
my dad went and had coffee at the sun
with ozzy smith in minnesota
and they hung out still might have each
other's phone numbers to this day that's
hysterical yeah
just having a coffee with ozzy we did us
we did a
local celebrity uh at the mets single a
in
coney island oh yeah uh the um what are
they the brooklyn cyclops yeah we
cyclones yeah we did this
and we uh i was the captain of my team
was um uh
uh not phil uh not phil sims uh john uh
quarterback for the giants no it's
bengals oh boomer signing
um yeah sorry about that boom yeah shout
out to chad
uh and q uh we we were we were up and q
made an
error and it was it was a bass clearing
error it was loaded bases
and it was inside the park grand slam
because q
q field but he was talking and didn't
want to feel the ball that landed fair
by first base he was playing first base
and it landed fair and they thought it
was foul and they just picked it up and
for some reason
he for some reason i think he was caught
up in all the hype he threw the ball to
center field
murray was murray was in center field he
just threw the ball to murray
and and the base is cleared and then
boomer at a charity game
because he's so competitive and that put
us down he literally like hit his glove
and just screamed
pull your head out of your ass i swear
to god and it was like sick children and
everything there
yeah it was weird but he just you know
the guy went through that's like when
pete rose barreled over the catcher like
broke his leg in the all-star game for
no reason
but i guess if they listen that that's a
double-edged sword it's like these guys
get to that level because they're
maniacs
see that right there it was um i guess
it was we also did an impractical
by the way shout out to a gary paron on
the cyclones there was one there
uh uh does joker's bobble head day
okay so they made bobbleheads of us yeah
and if you look at me i do not i look
like a dominican landlord you look like
i look like a dominican substitute
teacher you know who you look like you
look exactly like
sean king i do pull up sean king that's
the sean king bubble and job
yeah yeah so if you want to get the sean
king behind
it's the shuffle
we should do that we should get the
bubbling so we're making sean king
bubble with dolls here
i got a case of him i would never kill
him out because
it's like can we give him out as these
are the short we made a short kick bible
i hope i have i i know i have a few more
we got to give him out of showing
i'll scratch my name off the bottom i
will put sean and take
[ __ ] okay what could he be holding look
at this sean king
i mean in fairness q doesn't look like
kiwi the q looks like donnie wahlberg
dude i swear to god before the words
came out of your mouth i never thought
it but i was going to say he looks like
tony warren
she looks like pee-wee herman look like
kiwi herman joe looks like pee-wee
herman and mer looks like murray
wow they did a terrible job on these
bobble heads i mean i
straight up look like she won kings 100
they said it's the sean king bobblehead
night
i don't know what happened but this is
sean yeah i mean brooklyn cyclone shout
out
i mean the worst bob lights in the game
but great team great franchise
i mean that's hilarious
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i remember when i saw it too it
looked thank you guys so much you know
yeah when i saw it you know i ca i mean
look i got it i can only
i can't be honest it can't be anything
right yeah i i hope it didn't you know
you look at it you gotta be like
this this is perfect so i've never once
in my life seen you with glasses on
no i wear glasses really yeah from time
to time sometimes i go on
sometimes i go on a nice run with them
yeah
really sometimes i'll do glasses for
like a week or two and then there was a
season i did them every
when i first got my glasses i went to
get and the guy was like you need
glasses and i was like he said you need
it in your whole life you have an
astigmatism in each eye and i said what
is that and then he just gave me glasses
and
i don't wear them all the time why do
you why does everybody have an animal
except you you have a carton of milk
no i have what is that i think i think i
have hand sanitizer but i could be wrong
oh which is because i'm a germaphobe
does come in handy in the pan it comes
in handy in the panty um
yeah that's how germ germaphobia they
everyone believes that i mean i i really
am but like
my bobble head my bobble head has
yeah it's sean king and donnie wahlberg
and pete what does murr have i don't
understand murder
the cat on the show murder didn't have
it mur didn't have an animal he's
yeah he's got a cat on his shoulder i
don't know why i know what it is it
might be a ferret because we say murray
looks like a ferret oh third okay
all right again that does again no
distracts cyclops but it looks nothing
like a pharah oh disrespect to anybody
shout out all these shout outs shout out
shout out purell shout out dogs and cats
here's the thing you did they did the
impractical joker bobblehead night and
true tv and all that but they just
didn't
it's not someone
to sculpt the head yeah they were just
like just think of what you think he
looks like yeah just what it is yeah
and so there you go so there you go but
uh yeah and gq
does look like donnie he looks like
donnie wahlberg oh
all right well listen that was a another
fun episode of hey babe which we did not
get to anything we want to
talk about anything i know uh but next
episode we're gonna get to it yeah yeah
we will but you did see my mom's taped
you saw that we shot yeah we saw it we
saw rifle through
she also puts a plaque of jesus up right
underneath him there you go and she's
also got yeah she's and which is which i
love
she has the uh she has uses old uh glass
bottles for a flower
for flowers yes yes yes some glass
bottles
yeah this is just everywhere and picture
jesus everywhere so don't
think you're not cracking that window
but he's guarding that window
yeah believe it or not don't even think
about it don't even think about it
all right baby i i yeah that flew we
didn't get to anything uh what can you
do christy comedy.com
savile cats a volcano yep and
savilecountercomedy.com
and whatever our youtube name is that
we're going to discuss now because joe
derosa just got here
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey